an amazing night for everyone who works
at fox news media during our first ever
spotlight awards dinner the event
honoring the incredible work done by
employees here at the network fox news
media ceo suzanne scott highlighting the
very important role everyone plays
our success at fox news media is a
reflection of all your achievements
dedication collaboration and hard work
we do have the best team in the business
and it's important we celebrate our
success
tonight we also celebrate individual
achievements the name comes from the
idea of shining a light on colleagues
that do amazing work and make incredible
contributions the fives very own rock
star producer mina pertussis honored as
one of our unsung heroes
mina has tackled immense personal
challenges and never wavered she is
always optimistic encouraging and is a
rock star on a show full of them i can
remember sitting next to mina pertesis
in the newsroom she was such a joyful
person and she taught me everything
about eye news and booking guests and
you are a a ray of sunshine for all of
us who get the privilege of working with
you and i'm so thankful for you and she
has been a part of the five since the
beginning when we started 11 years ago
and it was a big night for greg and the
entire gutfeld team who took home the
impact award for their hit late night
show exclamation point a reason to laugh
or have a little fun has never been more
needed
and this smart show
has become a weeknight hit the 2021
spotlight impact award goes to the
gutfeld show and the team
all that suzanne said to me when this
show started was to make people laugh
and make people feel good and they
didn't tell me what not to say they
didn't tell me any political direction
we never could have done this show
without the support of suzanne scott the
support of just fox letting us do what
we do
the spotlight awards also recognizing
employees across four other categories
including community service
we had also five rising stars
an inclusion ambassador of the year and
innovator of the year
and then in a very emotional moment fox
news paying tribute to photojournalist
pierre zakrzewski who was killed
reporting in ukraine our london bureau
chief dragon petrovic accepted the award
on pierre's behalf and it was a
beautiful night a wonderful celebration
and the spotlight awards are super fun
exciting uh here judge you enjoyed your
experience there last night you know you
know what was great about it suzanne
scott who's i'm you know the president
of the company obviously i mean the
ability for so many people to have a
the the chance to talk with her and to
be with her her recognizing and touching
everyone it shows what what kind of
company this is and greg what you said
about never being told what to say what
not to say i mean that's what fox is
about i mean they they really give us a
lot of uh a lot of ability to say what
we want there's no direction
and it's just and your whole team was
there yeah yeah it was it was a shame
that jesse wasn't there so i could rub
his face in it
in your face jesse i got an award no you
know what
people know that i'm a i'm pretty much
like no emotional per i like i like to
do good work i don't care about how you
feel at work what did you get the award
or did your staff got the award oh so
you didn't get anything i i got this i
just wanted to click like a proud father
i'm like a professor but my point being
that like this this company is a rare
thing when you actually do good work and
also feel good while you're doing it
that's not always the case in people's
jobs you know that's not but in this
case it's like
anybody that is in this situation is
incredibly lucky and i consider myself
very lucky and it was very much like a
family i mean everyone was close
everyone was uh was happy to be there
and everyone was making fun of everyone
right harold
the entire night the i i was most also
moved by all the people we honored all
the people that were recognized for
their tireless work to help make the
network a success and then even
highlighting the not only unsung heroes
but the rising stars in the country i
thought was just a great great thing and
i got to tell you greg i thought you
gave a great speech oh thank you uh i
thought it was it was humane it was
fitting and it was jesse you were missed
just so you know i had it i had a great
time last night it was a great event i
thought you spoke really eloquently
and i can't wait for next year when
primetime staff gets the award and i
thought i thought brett's piece on
pierre was was outstanding yeah it was
really really special night and we thank
you uh employees for making it possible
for us to do our jobs hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else